all right oh we don't have prompter can
we can we fix that really quick
all right here we go
now what residency do you rep at home
okay you know we're repping lv over here
on las vegas now and that's what local
hat company residency is all about so
angelo and andrew are here to gear us up
for football season and beyond because
these hats can be worn all year round
all the time especially ahead of our
raiders home opener this sunday welcome
guys thanks for having us rocky thanks
chase we appreciate it i i you guys
these are some of my favorite hats shout
out to zach another one of the owners
right he's actually he's actually at a
photo shoot right now with darren waller
of the raiders he is he is he's you're
going to see some great content coming
from it we love it so let's get let's
get to it who are you guys repping where
you guys from so we're from vegas most
our lives right middle school high
school college um just always having a
way to represent our city we never
really had that growing up right the
writers and golden knights they came so
much later absolutely but then obviously
we wanted to have a way to represent our
residency opposed to representing a
corporation or a team and just really
giving back to that and just associating
with you know our purpose and what the
residency is and that's what the company
is all about so you guys make hats not
just for lv you guys see lv reps here
but you guys make them for all states
everywhere yeah so we're currently in 14
markets and we're excited to say that
another five markets are releasing
before the end of the year little sneak
peeks miami has come in we got
jacksonville we've got some good things
coming in okay okay okay now let's talk
about the hot tub let's separate you
guys from you know everybody else yeah
so it's won our brand mission and our
vision right but with this collaboration
it was really giving back to the
community so with the darren waller
foundation and obviously darren waller's
blessing we released the waller one the
waller two and the waller three we're
actually seeing some photos of your guys
right now there he is
here are his customized hats he actually
designed these with you guys in
partnership that really spoke to his
journey his legacy past and present and
what his future really does look like
wow okay so what else um you know we
have these two these are some of your
classics right yeah so really with the
waller 50 of the proceeds are going to
the darren waller foundation only 83 of
them are being made wow because 83 is
his number you know it i know it's smart
very limited but these other styles and
the styles that you see behind we have
the strip as an homage obviously we all
know the strength i have like five of
those i love the straps
and we got the truck and then we have
some other styles also behind us always
to represent and tie back to the city so
cool and also you guys at home can
customize your hats as well with you
guys so tell everybody how they can rep
too yeah so head to residency.com you
see it behind us or check out all of our
social handles at residency on instagram
facebook twitter check us out thank you
angelo and andrew wrap your residency
thank you
we're